gerade haben wir unsere kamera aufgebaut
vor dem hilfszentrum da heulen schon
wieder die sirenen
das ist fliegeralarm hier im zentrum der
stadt und die leute ging es alle in ihre
schutzkeller auch wir müssen jetzt hier
weggehen ein paar minuten später können
wir weiter arbeiten hier in niesky
die innenstadt ist geschmückt mit den
porträts der ukraine die in den letzten
acht jahren sterben im krieg gegen
russland
mit ski knapp 300 kilometer südwestlich
von kiew auf halben weg nach lemberg an
die polnische grenze
dahin ist auch diese familie unterwegs
und der vater ist gar nicht glücklich
darüber dass wir ihre abreise im
hinterhof unseres hotels filmen er will
nicht dass wir denken er machte sich aus
dem staub
filmen sie lieber wir kämpfen die wir
durch ich bringe hier nur die kinder weg
und komme zurück nach kiew und werde
kämpfen
wir werden unsere hauptstadt und die
ukraine verteidigen wir geben unser land
nicht auf
für jeden gast der preis und sein zimmer
räumt gibt es mindestens ein dutzend
neuankömmlinge und nachrücker die schon
warten das hotel jannik soll ist mit
kriegsausbruch zum anlaufpunkt für
flüchtende aus den östlichen
landesteilen geworden
die junge frau die ich im hotel treffe
hat sich aus der großstadt nie pro bis
hierhin durchgeschlagen
wir wohnen an der grenze zu städten wie
bonn jetzt und kharkiv wo die lage jetzt
sehr gefährlich ist
und wegen der kinder haben wir uns
entschieden weg zu gehen aber schon
heulen die sirenen und ihr kleiner sohn
mischa unterbricht das interview er hat
die logik des krieges schon
verinnerlicht
mama das ist die rede
wir müssen runter in den keller gehen
und uns verstecken bis die sirene nicht
mehr halt
das ist jetzt für keller in den jetzt
alle gäste des hotels unter geben müssen
[Musik]
ja das ist jetzt hier mittlerweile für
uns alltag hätte ich mir auch nicht
vorstellen können das noch mal in dieser
form zu erleben aber die fliegeralarm
jetzt in ihrer häufigkeit zu und jetzt
müssen wir erstmal hier im keller
bleiben
ganz gleichgültig wo einen das
unheimliche heulen überrascht man muss
alles stehen und liegen lassen und in
den nächsten schutzraum ob das nun
mitten in der stadt oder beim einkaufen
im baumarkt ist überall sind bereiche
ausgewiesen in denen man relativ sicher
sein kann da wartet man dann einige
lange und bange minuten bis endlich
wieder entwarnung gegeben wird wo die
menschen in ständiger angst vor
russischen luftangriffen leben wundert
es nicht dass uns das fernsehteam aus
einem nato stark bei dreharbeiten in der
stadt immer wieder passanten ansprechen
und fordern dass der westen endlich
eingreifen muss wir verteidigen jetzt
ganz europa gegen diesen putin gegen die
unterjochung gegen diese mörder und
damit schützen wir auch sie und da
sollten sie alle mögliche hilfe leisten
militärische materielle alles nur
erdenkliche und die ukraine zu
verteidigen
die werbeflächen an der hauptstraße sind
freigeräumt geworben wird hier nun für
eine flugverbotszone
das fordert auch die ehemalige
ministerpräsidentin die wir über das
internet erreichen
eins kann ich ihnen mit großer
sicherheit sagen den luftraum über der
ukraine zu schließen würde unseren sieg
bedeuten
ich glaube nicht dass putin einlenken
und verhandeln wird und auch sanktionen
werden ihn nicht aufhalten egal wie
streng sie sind die zivilisierte welt
muss das jetzt beenden und eine
flugverbotszone
das ist ein anderes wort für sie
immer wieder treffe ich männer aber auch
frauen aller berufszweige und
altersgruppen die sich zum dienst an der
waffe melden wollen
ich will meine heimat verteidigen die
menschen verteidigt die zivilisten ich
bin eigentlich gegen krieg gegen jede
art von militärischen handlungen dort wo
menschen sterben aber man hat den krieg
zu uns gebracht da muss ich alles tun um
mütter kinder und frauen zu verteidigen
das kino von ahmed ski ist die zentrale
anlaufstelle für alle die hilfe brauchen
oder helfen wollen
sergej registriert die kämpfer die oft
ihre frauen und kinder richtung polen
gebracht haben und nun an die front
wollen
der frage nach der stimmung verantwortet
er mit der ukrainischen form des sieges
zeichens dem dreizack alles läuft prima
sagt er aber fröhlich ist nicht
der krieg hat auch seine familie
auseinandergerissen
nur gott kann den russen verzeihen
im kinosaal stapeln sich kleider essen
decken die spende aus der gegend
abgegeben haben und die hier vorsortiert
und an die flüchtlinge ausgegeben werden
und wir treffen hier so viele frauen die
uns erzählen es ist einfach für sie
wahnsinnig wichtig dass sie helfen dass
sie einfach in dieser situation nicht
nur still und untätig zu hause sitzen
etwas machen menschen unterstützen
zusammenstehen das ist im moment das was
die ukraine hier in dieser stadt sehr
bewegt
die bedürftigen schreiben auf was sie
brauchen und anhand ihrer zettel werden
dann die hilfspakete zusammengestellt
erklärt mir lubov sie ist 69 und war
schon auf dem majdan dabei
seit kriegsbeginn ist sie hier im
einsatz und kaum noch daheim ihre
wohnung hat sie viel flüchtlingsfamilien
überlassen und sich selbst bei der
nachbarin einquartiert wir treffen sie
um sieben uhr morgens sie zeigt uns die
improvisierte flüchtlingsunterkunft in
die sich ihre wohnung verwandelt hat es
sind kinder und mütter aus charkiw und
saccharose sie warten auf die chance
nach polen weiter zu reisen
eine der familien ist für 20 minuten
aufgebrochen und die anderen werden sich
wahrscheinlich bald auch auf den weg
machen aber wollten zumindest mal zeigen
wie viele familien zusammen in einer
wohnung unterkunft gefunden haben
gestern abend hat sie mit der nachbarin
die nachrichten geschaut und geweint
erzählt sie an eine lösung durch
verhandlungen glaubt sie nicht
und damals haben wir drei monate lang
auf eine friedliche verhandlungslösung
gewartet aber am ende wurden doch unsere
jungen leute erschossen
ich glaube nur an die jungs die uns
verteidigen und die am ende auch siegen
werden
auf dem bahnhof von manage ski fahren
erstaunlicherweise immer noch züge nach
fahrplan auf gleis 6 steht der zug nach
kiew die frage ob das nicht sehr
gefährlich sei will die zugbegleiterin
mir nicht beantworten
und während sie losfahren kommt da
drüben der zug aus kies nach lemberg
total überfüllt sie hocken in den gängen
am ausgang auf der defekten toilette
helfer bringen wasser und nahrung
gibt die flaschen nach hinten weiter
das hier ist zwar kinder bei der macht
satt du kannst du ruhig essen
auf dem markt von manage ski kaufen sie
blumen zum internationalen frauentag ein
wichtiger feiertag für russen und
ukrainer aber der blutige krieg hat die
bande zwischen den völkern zerrissen
früher waren wir tatsächlich wie
geschwister aber nach dem was nun
passiert es gibt es keine
gemeinsamkeiten mehr
nicht einmal an denselben gott glauben
sie noch auch die kirchen beider staaten
gehen seit jahren getrennte wege jetzt
hilft nur noch beten sagt vater
alexander der die messe feiert am beginn
der fastenzeit im orthodoxen kalender
ist es der tag der vergebung doch an
vergebung denken die ukraine in diesen
tagen der gewalt und des leids nicht
nicht einmal die fronten unter ihnen